pretty simple and not controversial
Aldean argues out of control crime and
BLM riots wouldn't fly in small town
America
but the woke think that's racist and
aldine's now defending himself and calls
the outrage quote meritless I want to go
to the former MTV VJ is it DJ or Vijay
it's video jockey video job Downtown
Julie Brown isn't here so I guess uh why
would CMT pull this uh they're afraid of
backlash they're afraid of a small and
vocal mob rising up and contacting their
sponsors and having their sponsors pull
ads and revenue
um You Know music video television
actually isn't very popular right now
even CMT people don't sit for long
periods of time like they used to in the
90s when we didn't have the internet
there was no Facebook uh and so it's
hard enough getting an audience so it's
just fear of people rising up and
getting these sponsors to pull out and
Greg now he's number one everywhere yeah
well it gets to see in CMT stands for
cowardice yeah we'll be right back no
you you know uh I think he learned in
today's world you can't depict reality
right because reality is racist so you
can't have mug shots you can't have
clips of rioting because that tells a
story that has been shaped out of
existence by the media but please play
one incident by a police officer a fatal
interaction between a cop and a suspect
100 200 times a day until you believe
that that is the reality and everybody
assumes and studies show this that a
thousand uh blacks are killed by cops
every year maybe it's even more I think
Democrats believe it's somewhere between
a thousand and four thousands so the
results are that that's what we believe
and when you show that you upset the
left because they know that they made
those images those images possible they
degraded the cops they defend
criminality this is a media driven
activist-driven problem that has been
lasting since these riots we have not
recovered from this and all he's saying
is this wouldn't happen here I don't
know maybe he wouldn't it is a mirror
though everything's a mirror uh hip-hop
is a soundtrack to violence and some
other cultures so if you're upset about
this tough beans right like a pro-crime
hip-hop song not canceled but an
anti-crime country song canceled judge
well yeah you know you have these rap
songs like uh F the you know the rest of
it Donald Trump or
um you get some of these rap songs where
they actually talk about rape they talk
about killing cops that's not that stuff
is never censored okay but CMT for them
to do this don't they know who Their
audience is don't they know who buys
Jason Aldean's records I mean what is
wrong with them and the whole idea of
the First Amendment and freedom of
speech I mean the hip-hop rap artists
get to say whatever they want but you
get a conservative there who literally
has documentation of what is happening
in America America of the truth of the
facts and he's not trying to portray
them in any way other than how they are
and he gets you know canceled or the the
the song gets pulled I'm gonna buy a
bunch of those songs good and usually
the left Jessica
Embraces free expression art how many
times have you heard oh it's art can't
censor art yeah
I didn't think that it deserved to be
pulled I think it's a you can have a
conversation about it because it's not
just saying you know this doesn't happen
in small towns it's saying if it did
happen in a small town we've all got
guns and we're going to take matters
into our own hands which is vigilanteism
no it's a good message it stops it is my
vigilante as well I would also say that
I do think it's a strange choice to
perform this in front of a courthouse
where a boy was lynched an 18 year old
was lynched in 1927. do you think he
knows that you know what just tell him
good enough there have been so many
music videos and so many in front of
places that exact location no one said
anything don't you think he's trying to
show that there hasn't been that much
progress and that you know with black
lives matter is is violating the law
themselves at this point rioting I'm
just saying I imagine that there are
available later courthouses where an 18
year old boy wasn't lynched again I said
I didn't think that it should be taken
down I think you should have these
conversations I think what Cheryl Crow
is contributing to this talking about
the fact that she actually grew up in a
much smaller town than Jason Aldean did
and finds this to be offensive and
promoting the use of God she's so great
that's great so great
everyone loves Sheryl Crow yeah she
doesn't set the standard the American
people do fine fine his record and try I
don't you're right it is fine yeah is
that it thank you up next that's it
that's it the real life Castaway a guy
and his dog survive getting lost at sea
for three months
I went on Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now